book you about you taking people on
Tyson Fury heavyweight champion of the
world I saw the column you wrote there
the other day saying you want to go
head-to-head with them obviously not in
the ring I suspect but you know on the
serious issue about some of the comments
he's been making about homosexuality
about so many other issues I mean do you
think he's an appropriate person to be
nominated for a Sports Personality of
the year no I don't I mean in the end
it's not for me to tell the BBC what to
do with their programming or for that
matter sky but and I looked Tyson Fury
that my real problem is that Tyson has
equated homosexuality with pedophilia
and actually that is a very dangerous
and equation to make because it means
that we don't take child abuse seriously
actually the vast majority of child
abuse happens within the family and it's
heterosexual so if you really want to
tackle child abuse and you've got an
depart for anything else there are there
are millions of gay and lesbian couples
the whole world over and who would never
touch a child except and to you know
prevent harm to them and for that matter
there are thousands of thousands in this
country who have provided the loving
caring and gentle home to children so
there is something deeply offensive
about what he said but it's it's not the
offense that I care about it's the fact
that it means that we'd end up not
taking child abuse seriously have you
had any response from him I mean he's
not revived he would like mr. florea mr.
fury I don't know which camera mr. fury
please get in touch come to tea at the
House of Commons and we can talk about
your issues